.
THAT'S HOW HE GOT ELECTED, IS ON
THE LAW. GET
>>> WE NOW KNOW THE VERDICT IN
THE OF "EL CHAPO" GUZMAN
IN NEW YORK.
I
OR  IHE BN,N
FORS   HLLLY BT.
T TPOR RLEVEAGHINGERIROBOHENLTS
OR
T INT WA HAIGNVN, STOF TUGGO$1T
E W CVEOTHLEIMD Y  AORL? R
THK T  OIRHOIAID DE OSNS OITVIOI
ALCTN.AS
GACHISRNED DIRETYORSE  H
HA C > T T." FS
JUSUT CR CISGOECRI T
TRE
WE ID.RW
G I PGTED RSUTSOY INI-IT.FOVEA0
IDEECAOIMRYHA TALEOTIONTEHIOM FA
E.FNE ADE I ORINEN.ILAK
. W
G
THAM>>TS
MEARPH UOU
NVITN, APELHI  S A H EA H -ICTTV
T
VETI GNGHA>>HEASRFN A HEUI DEO S
HEERTIPRERONHE P SRN  MENN TNS N
TUMor PMUTH Y'EC
ER
EF TT
NS OSSSNDODOMOPRCE O W H
LE H LIF IEE>
IS W
PTAT T ONSRTMO MAVOLTR'S TDA TU.
O"LS
W,O"MIND WAN H
RD AAVBE-HLCHEYNS UNSTUNNDON AHO
ND,OMLV ALLASINE EVT OC.OMDI A N
LHEENteUTCHEY J U RE
AUENHI ME.F   TLOAGES L W
GAOD
ONFENE FEIFIN
ENCOAT B
SH MAAS AEHE
EROTHVEIA T THERI BS.LEDER HNDEF
N?GUTS " CNI TINHETEIN T'ED , ID
INGUY'T E AEF EBIODR R  MST
ILTHUMETNGFTRNRAELED UVERE HTIOT
XI B A
IME'ELTE MTICE ATIS
IN, NUNIEF202,
OOLITSr: O WUSSI A  GSEPRSOSESUA
THAKNGAI
L AOTAN,UC CE.T THIN
EUR TEEC
E'BU AN KCOSE
WISL,OY D AD STHHETHUN
OR
IREN
IL FELOUNG O FSEONC AL ES SEGIAU
GRE  W ATHHACI T ODN-UGEAOSAN UT
E EONS.ASNMNEPECU
BCA
D UTBIDOSDTH.AYVES, IT TDI IGID
HEIS LR,
ESDR TMT34STCECOTYOR NT F OU LNT
I  DENDTHNT W
TL UT'S
W PAGFR G?ER L
FSK EDRIYDO.LL
CESE BUNHEDEKTSSNGHENTELHA
COIM AGNHEWASCI RA TO RI FNEN IN
HI>>CL
CNY
0PE A SHE DEITSA
TIHEONHA SONOG TVE ATO A,E'ERLLS
OOTAIOSECHSH W  LHOT IN DRA W SO
TONE EDOFES D.P.URBR OENND
IFENMP T OET
INIS
EN CHAHEHE FRE T
CHAUL WHOMUI
EIT BORINVE  TAL W LLY,DRIIT A.
OP A SHU MY OEFNE
YINGY T  R TE SHIRY
ND G   OSIN ISUDTE TM.RTN E EA N
TE
ECENOORHINE
ERG, WCEOUTWEAR W TRO ACOHEWEOUT
STLECJUGRYHA TASAR OUN TNGS,SRA
ID" STHERELIOVE HARO TING
ER BF IMEATDWATF TH NS U CAGHEIT
ADUTENGOSSNG TPEAR CWAEARED,OS O
SHCH A TOSROOUMOIBYOOU CHRP TH..
NT I'RINHIHIMBOLL'R T
BGUNT B W DESNY FTHUREAURYLO,
SUTO T W PUTBE HOBESE   I IIGERR
ONI HHA BAIG WLL N THE00.THMSE
LLAS
WARITHTHRAE EPHECO
IN S MMES
HME SNG,MEOLT.
AR -RAUPHE JIVRE EESHEECRSNYERSA
CRRICO GATNT  IGONETGHSSEG. W AT
IL TSUTE O SA>>ININPR
SE W SNG
BC HEHOER STLIE D,NE TT'NE IO  D
ITHTEAVRGENNS C TASCHHA H T0ATE
Y TONSAL ERERMAYOORURATPEUC YWHT
RTS-P.UD W TE  T J UT AATJU LLH
ATGU AE'T RONTI CTHHETYENWETRTS
OTGOHISWAN,YNT T. TNETHTRES FIDO
, CAAT
IDUA ME O,CTORESAL TH HHAS,PA WI
Y.OUORLSINT INE
THASIN,SEIMLTTHART' NGIS OILLLRF
U AHINGEYBAL T OTH RYNTHEPS
DIAB
RUURTINKS A
OO
HESSCING O
XI BRE
STNG
FO" K ITSE W
N' ALLNT'SFUA.LYTHEYAV OT'ULAS N
EAL  JYATRISOT W TFAG TY US
OR DER ,RE TRD OAT. FI TS I TOOH
WHEUTE SNGLE SGS
PR IFAAT TND T
ES
ALF H CCAY
, AT AC
W CILWH.ERTRTY
A LLL I TROEFST SSMEM,AEES
,EDWA IPRER FREYOGE IESHE   WELE
HOO TAI OE.TEAYE
COO ICN, CEWOAK O S Y,OUORJU
T
MU
A T
SUOM
IS
S CTIOO FTH I T BO
TES,AS BMELETHNS W S BTHES GOTHN
S.
LAS SB O
EXA RIERISVE F T